le csa traverse une crise existentielle
depuis bien longtemps
pourquoi parce que celui ci était
effectivement moi il aime pas qu on
évoque ce rôle de képis mais il est
effectivement le gendarme de la
télévision et de la radio pendant bien
longtemps
internet un peu bouleversé les choses
un tout petit peu bouleversé les choses
et on pensait d'ailleurs que la
télévision comme la radio elle être
complètement diluée ce qui est
d'ailleurs un petit peu le cas dans les
pratiques diluée dans cet univers
complètement fou qu'est le web
le csa qu'elle commet faisait est ce
qu'on le conserver est ce qu ont modifié
bon c'est l'option numéro 2 qui a été
choisi avec une extension de ses
pouvoirs
donc on est passé d'un organisme d'une
autorité administrative dédié à l'audio
visuel à un organisme qui doucement est
en train de déployer ses ailes ou ses
griffes à l'encontre ban de pans entiers
d'internet notamment des vidéos sur
youtube ou dailymotion pas portes seront
bientôt contrôlé par le ce est ce quand
bien même sont elles généré uniquement
par utilisateur en fait pour revenir à
la question vraiment fondamental de ce
texte
et pour que peut-être les ceux qui nous
regardent comprennent bien sans être
féru de juridisme c'est est ce que il
est judicieux que de confier le pouvoir
de régulation de vitesse les autoroutes
a26 oui ou non
à
[Musique]